here's a
bit of a sim test for you all right
because you know some guys are going how
do i know i'm simping when do i know
that i'm simply like how do i stop
we'll get to the solution in a minute
but how do i know that i'm a simp
all right well you can start by
constantly trying to impress women are
you constantly trying to impress women
right are you constantly you know
telling them that they're beautiful
on social media are you constantly
dropping hearts and dm'ing them
whenever they post a picture somebody
that um
you know you're following because you're
a big fan right
are you ask yourself that question i
don't follow
any women on any of my social media i
don't like there's lots of beautiful
women out there that i can look at and
admire of course because beauty is
something that you're going to just
check out right but i don't follow them
because i don't want to get distracted
out you know for my purpose i know what
i'm doing
i don't need to look at you know boobs
and butt all day long
i'm not a dork i got stuff to do right
that is something you got to ask
yourself are you constantly
trying to impress women showering women
with compliments
and money okay the money is a big part
of this simp economy today because
a lot of these thirst traps out there on
the different platforms as a matter if
it's twitch
only fans instagram instagram snapchat
snap insta
gram only fan mix it up whatever comes
next
a lot of you guys are throwing loads of
money at these women
loads of money cam girls like
these women couldn't care
let me put it to you this way if she was
walking down the street with a glass of
water in her hand
and you were on fire she'd probably keep
walking while drinking the glass of
water
okay there's no like you're not going to
get any benefit out of throwing
money at a woman she's got to have
genuine burning desire for you can't
buy your way into her heart you can
buy your way into her heart if you got
loads of money
i've seen some rich nerds i've
shared the stair this uh story before
there was a little danny devito looking
dude that owned three of the buildings
back in the 90s when i was working down
at young and shepherd
and he kept a whole like wall full of
exotic cars down there
different girl every time i saw him
different hot girl every time
you know every time i saw him little
danny devito looking dude
well that amount of money will get you
the girls but the amount of money that
most sims throw at the girls
it's nothing it just it just piles in
it's like 10 bucks from this guy
10 bucks from this guy oh he made a 24
donation
oh this guy's a super fan he paid a 100
500 whatever
it doesn't even matter she she just
looks at you guys as paychecks
you're basically tax cattle
are you white knighting are you
constantly trying to
swoop in to protect the honor of milady
are you
white knights are the worst i gotta tell
you white knights simps
simply white knights they're brutal most
of them
most of them come from a weak household
okay where
father was non-existent or he was just a
[ __ ]
and mom just you know molded him into
some
weak pathetic beta male she basically
molded him into what the father never
was
because she wanted that in her life
but at the end of the day she doesn't
want
to sleep with that little boy you know
she sends that little boy off in the
world calls him a man
but he's still a little boy in his head
thinking that if he's bending the knee
and always nice and
doing the dishes you know we we have
this
epidemic now of chore play with married
couples
and if you're not familiar with what
chore play is it's basically where
husbands are doing chores around the
house that would conventionally be done
by
his wife in order to get intimacy
so he's trying to exchange doing the
dishes
uh taking care of the kids to
extracurriculars cover
you know cut the grass put away the
dishes hang the shelves
he's trying to exchange all of that for
a little bit
of starfish intimacy in the bedroom
once every couple weeks if he's lucky
that's what chore play is
that's simping type of behavior that's
that's it's silly
right you're trying to negotiate desire
with a woman
i will do all of these things for you
because we are equals
and you will want to enthusiastically
jump my bones this is the thinking they
have going through their heads
that's not how it goes down women need
to have genuine
burning desire for you i think it's the
second or third chapter in my book i
spent a lot of time putting that
information together for you
and giving you a way to assess it
because it's important to understand
what it looks like
and why you should always seek to get it
from women if you're not getting it
you're wasting your time
a scale of one to ten nine and ten would
be genuine burning desire seven
eight would be indifferent she kind of
likes you but she's not sure
maybe she needs to [ __ ] test you a
little bit to see if you really are the
man that she thinks that you might be
and then six to one the tractor
she could not care if you stop breathing
if you didn't get up in the morning
you are invisible to her and almost
all the simping behavior goes to women
that are completely oblivious to who you
are
you're invisible to them they don't care
sim test getting little to
zero success with women what does that
mean i mean
if you want to go out with a girl you'll
want to be intimate with her you want to
uh have a good time with her are you
getting success with that or not
because if you're not you're probably
sinking too much
other stuff that ties into that like
texting back way too fast and
persistently and good morning and good
night every freaking day
you know multiple days straight several
times in a row there was this one
um screenshot i had i think i shared it
on an instagram story at one point
and it was like this this guy just kept
going down he's like
day number 13 of asking you to be my
girlfriend day number 14 of asking you
my girlfriend it's like every day this
dude would send a text message to this
chick
and i got this screen capture i don't
know who sent it to me but it's like
every single day with a new time date
stamp dude's like
day number 16 i'm asking you to be my
girlfriend day number 17
it just kept going on and on and on
simping right
texting back too persistently too fast
too enthusiastically
when she's got no desire for you you
know what i'm saying
um let me get these supers right here
hold on
one man's chorus rich don't you think
toxic masculinity is kind of a hoax
it doesn't exist outside of website
headlines it is not enforced on men
masculinity is weaponized against men
real men do x um
is it a hoax yeah all that it is is just
anything that the feminine imperative
doesn't like that doesn't
serve it okay um
we're not making enough money we don't
have enough days off we should have more
free
insert whatever it is and some guy
or a group of men get in the way of that
they'll just throw
that's toxic masculinity on that right
there's no such thing there's just
masculinity okay
when there's a war when the floods come
when there's a hurricane
when there's a tornado and they got a
call in the national guard to come and
fix [ __ ]
when the two planes slammed into the
twin towers
okay 20 odd years ago and they came
and they were about to come crumbling
down who was running up into those
buildings
men firefighters police officers it was
men that were running up those stairs to
try to save
everybody up there screaming not being
able to find a way out and they call
that toxic masculinity today
it's just conventional masculinity
because again like i said anytime the
feminine impaired
a female first primary social order
doesn't get what it wants from men
then they start slapping labels on it to
try to insult and degrade
and diminish what it is that you're
doing
and yeah it's a form of weaponization
you know i would agree with that
you